all right
we are we are now live for the birthday
bash
i've got uh a mug of a local
beer here trecker black bavarian one of
the very first
craft brews that i've ever had the
schrecker brewery
has been here in milwaukee wisconsin
for a long time it recently changed
hands as the original
owner tired so i've got my beer for a
toast i hope all of you do
mark smith says uh they dropped the
alcohol ban there last night in south
africa
where they they had done that as part of
their covid stuff
there's a whole conversation to be had
there about whether that was prudent or
not
so he's ready to join for today's toast
so let's uh toast to say
for each of us long lifetime
and plenty of uh productive
work to do and you know like alfred
hitchcock talks about
his vision of happiness as being a clear
road ahead
to engage in creative work let's uh
all toast to to that for for each one of
us
that's a that's a good beer it's been a
while since i've had it
and i'm really happy to have it again i
remember
when i turned 21 my mom had always been
kind of down on
you know underage drinking and i was in
the generation
where younger older people than us
actually could drink
at 18 and then they changed the law
while i was in high school and we were
all like oh this sucks right
and then i went off in the army and of
course i could drink on post and
in germany and came back and and on my
21st birthday
my mom actually you know she went out
and she came back and this was one of
the
beers of course the bottles were
different than their big and fat
that she brought and then there was the
special amber and i think there was
one other thing sprecker only had four
kinds at that
so a lot of people wishing happy
birthday uh thanks
i do have to mention i'm not yet 50.
the reason we're doing it early today is
because some of you may have seen on my
twitter
or facebook the democratic national
convention
is less than a block from here in the
wisconsin center
and there's probably going to be a lot
of craziness and chaos
so we wanted to make sure that we'd
actually have wi-fi
to be able to do this i don't know
what's gonna happen
they've already put up steel barricades
going all the way down our street
uh there's cops all over the place
there's dnc all over the place so
that's going on maybe you'll see you
know provided everything goes well i'll
take some photos
and maybe video over the next couple
days
um so let me read a few of the the
birthday wishes a lot of people are
saying
uh happy birthday ron says wish i were
50 again
i'll be saying that you know in a while
myself
i never thought i would get this old so
maybe ron you can relate to that as well
you know and i'm going to talk a little
bit about this in in a few moments but
man not only did i never think i'd be
this age but i also kind of feel like
there's still a
teenage 20 30 year old greg and me
still you know doing things and still
you know moving this this older body
around um but my heart feels young
and he says happy birthday from the next
room uh
that's as many of you know my my wife
and
partner and so many different things
she's over
literally in the other room this is
we're in the
spare bedroom where my my kids are
laughing bunk
and right now some longer things here
um camille says wish you long and great
life
um thanks yeah and to you too
uh i'm gonna talk about this in a bit 50
is a good vantage point for thinking
about well how much longer do i actually
have uh ikka
iraqi there we go says i wish you the
best love your videos they're super
helpful
thanks i'm glad that the videos are
helpful for you
some people have been like asking are
you going to keep on doing
videos and and you know why not why not
do another 10 years or 20 years provided
youtube
still you know maintains the
the same sort of thing that they're
doing and i suppose if you know that
platform goes down we could put them on
vimeo or
something else uh real lobby says happy
early birthday professor metal
thanks yeah we we had a great uh classic
medal class
yesterday um and
on my actual birthday i'm gonna spend
some time doing some writing and heavy
metal philosopher
um peter says happy early birthday
thanks for all that you do wish i found
your lectures channel sooner
you know you find them when you find
them like that i think epicurus
says somewhere that you know um there's
no like bad
age for beginning philosophy you just
start when you
you start uh kevin says i assume i'd be
dead by 50 blew past that
glad you're not um
yeah i mean it really puts things in
perspective you know for august
some of you may have seen me talking
about my dad
who uh now has been dead for more years
than he was ever alive he died he was
only 36 years old you know
and they couldn't find out what was
wrong with him even up the mayo clinic
which is one of the best places here in
the united states
really puts things in perspective i've
outlived him
um well when i turned uh 50 by
uh 14 years quite a long time
um kevin says i love your lectures hi
from miami
uh glad you like them must be pretty hot
down there right now
uh mike says i just turned 54 last month
it's been held a strange ride lately
yeah it's been in one weird year has it
not
um qqt
77 says i wish you the best you helped
me a lot to understand stoic philosophy
well good
yeah and that that is a sort of you know
area
that i that i work in um there's a
playlist for those who are interested
in stoic philosophy in particular that
you can just google sadler stoic
playlist and there's over 200 videos in
there now so that's kind of nice
um yashodara says a very happy birthday
your lectures are amazing they've helped
me in my hour of need
i wish you all the best wishes thank you
so much oh you're very welcome i'm glad
the lectures
are helpful to you and you know so i'm
gonna before i jump into talking about
50 let me say something about
um like retrospect about video lectures
and stuff like that
so i started recording my video lectures
when i was still at fayetteville state
university
in 2011
and one of the first one of the things
that told me
what was going on when i started posting
videos
was there were comments that were like
oh this is really helpful thanks for
that
and then there are lots of comments
where there are people saying things
like
my professor won't explain anything
thank you for doing this lecture
this has been really helpful because i
couldn't get anything out of this person
over here
i was like oh man that sucks for them
right but there's a lot of bad teachers
out there
they had not only a sense of like can't
effectively teach
but i think in the sense of don't want
to teach
and so if you're stuck with one of those
that's helpful and then there were a lot
of people who are like oh man i'm so
glad
i couldn't go to school i can't afford
to go to college but
watching these lectures lets me kind of
feel like i'm
in the classroom and getting to enjoy
some of that
so that told me that there was this
incredible
hunger out there that was not being
satisfied when i saw enough of these
like hundreds of comments
and that hunger is for something that's
kind of like a goldilocks thing not too
much not too little
it's for presentation of ideas in such a
way that it can relate to the
average person right or average students
um
so they they you know it's speaking
their language you could say
but at the same time it's not losing the
rigor it's not dumbing everything down
and
i was actually talking about there's
some ideas some examples here's how it
applied your own life
and so um you know
that there's a lot of people who want
that and it's not being served by our
typical media stuff you know anytime you
see like a philosopher in a tv show it's
usually kind of garbage
or it's really dumbed down and
oversimplified it's not being served by
our universities which
despite doing a little bit of outreach
are not
they're not reaching the ordinary person
so
um you know i saw a niche and i was like
well i'll do this
i may not be the best person for some of
these thinkers you know half our hagel
videos are a great example
i'm i'm you know i haven't written books
on hegel
you know i i've studied him quite a bit
but uh
i'm not a hegelian but nobody else is
going to do it so
you know i'll i'll do it right all right
let's see we got some more comments here
let me
address those uh iraq iraqi says how
many videos have you posted
so i think videos that i've publicly
posted because i do have some that i
like
create framing videos from my online
classes that i don't make public
um probably about 1700 or so
at this point in time i've taken a few
of them down
uh like when when youtube first started
you actually couldn't post anything
longer than 10 minutes
and then it was 15 minutes so some of
the i like did things in sequences and
then i took those down
and re-added them into longer ones
hangover says uh prior to the pandemic
were you
still going to metal shows if so will
you continue so in your 50s
uh well when the pandemic is over yeah
we're going to continue going to metal
shells
that's something that andy and i both
share in and
really enjoy
she has much wider tastes in music than
than i do
i mean i i do like some non-metal bands
like you know i like john cougar
mellencamp and i like duran duran
and you know things here and there but
um
for the most part it's been it's been
metal and
uh yeah the late the last show that we
saw we were we were actually scheduled
to see
deep purple and judas priest and didn't
get to because we were both sick
unfortunately that was last fall so
what was the last show we actually got
to see it might have been blue easter
cult
i i don't remember but i mean it's been
a while and
but we've seen a lot of a lot of people
you know we've seen uh
in recent years we've seen uriah heap
which was priest a couple times
kiss saxon um ace freely
rant when they were still arguably rat
there's a whole story to talk about
there um
we saw iron maiden and alice cooper here
in milwaukee at summerfest
years ago when we were still living in
new york uh
or maybe actually that might have been
before i i moved up
um and we've seen you know raven
and accept and udo on his own and
a whole bunch of other uh uh bands as
well
so yeah i hope we get to see them
uh mark says what's been your best
decade so far is that an
off kilter question um that is a good
question
best decade so far probably the last one
um i've been getting back in shape you
know
it's a struggle not so much on a
physical level but
on a time management level i would say
um you know the decade
began with uh
a divorce from previous marriage that
was
was no good but resulted in two two kids
who i love very much and then you know
um
sort of a whirlwind kind of
long-distance romance that then became a
face-to-face
living together and so this last decade
with andy has been
has been my best but we've you know
we've faced a lot of
challenges you know there have been all
sorts of um
job you know ups and downs and you know
we
live together and i'll tell this story
probably in one of the sandler's stories
when we moved in together we had all of
our books that much of which went into
storage she had two dogs and two cats
and we lived in what's called a carriage
house apartment with about 400 square
feet
total so and then now we live here of
course in milwaukee we were able to move
here
uh in the middle of the decade and we
have a nice apartment in the downtown
um you know teaching wise
point in time um so i'm kind of
fortunate that way
i've transitioned into online teaching
obviously the youtube videos i'm doing
something quite different than i did in
the past which is being kind of a
other than teaching in prison being a
rather traditional academic person
so so this has been pretty good
um leilani says happy birthday i'm happy
to found
to have found you enjoy your lectures
thank you very much glad glad you like
them
um it just skipped a little bit
uh here we go uh from
mr stufflebean uh
happy birthday so grateful for you and
all that you do
thanks very much that's that's nice ted
says uh
our td says happy birthday man wishing
you another healthy year going forward
yeah let's hope let's hope for good
health for all of us especially in a
time of pandemic right
um yeah says i'm
that i may have been a better professor
to him than many who taught them i made
philosophy more interesting
teaching is an art um yeah i i mean
i'm i'm really interested in the
philosophers
even the ones i don't agree with and i
try to communicate
some of that and i think it's coming
through effectively that that kind of
passion
not just for teaching when connecting
with people which i like to do because i
am kind of extroverted
if you haven't even figured that out um
but you know for the the ideas and the
philosophers it's
i'm kind of lucky in that i get to talk
about
people for for whom for the most part i
really like and admire
so that that's cool mark says the half
hour hegel series is like an extended
audio book
yeah you know and i think some of the
other series are like that that too so
that's cool so
uh irikali asks what am i drinking i
suppose some people may have tuned in
this is sprecker
brewery here in milwaukee one of the
first craft breweries
in the united states uh they're they're
black bavarian which is you know
essentially a shark beer
um it's very tasty it's got a good
sweetness to it
good bite to it um it's sort of you
think about like if a
a scout was a lager
and it was done well that's kind of what
it's like
all right ludentes says happy birthday
thank you for sharing your wealth of
knowledge you're very welcome
autodidact says happy birthday to our
online teacher you've been a source of
invaluable lessons
glad that it's been helpful for you dj
says
thanks for all the knowledge over the
years you're very welcome
uh alexios happy birthday i'd be
watching
more of your videos if i wasn't stuck
teaching myself high level calculus for
my econ grad courses
well that's there's nothing wrong with
that and you can always go back to the
videos later on right
calculus is something i really enjoyed
when i was a mathematics major
and taking a calculus class was part of
how i ended up becoming a mathematics
major
i you know i tested high right and so
when i went to lakeland college
uh not knowing anything about how
college worked
my advisor was like ah your math scores
are high
um because i took the sat when i was in
the army they wanted me to be an
officer he's like i'll throw you into
calc one and i was like
oh okay i mean i took the minimal amount
of math i had to to get through
high school which was at that time just
you know two years for me
because i had i already had like algebra
one when i went to uh
high school and i got into this cal
class
and the professor started talking about
the theory of limits
and i was like holy crap this is math
this is cool stuff you know
i've never had math taught to me like
that before it was just memorize these
equations
here's some proofs to do you know there
was never any like real discussion about
what was going on with it
in terms of ideas and there at lakeland
college
you know david haas and michael devaney
and then later on uh
maria we used to call her maria gk
because she had a very long
unpronounceable polish name and i don't
remember it offhand
but they were people who like made
mathematics
interesting to somebody like me who was
interested in ideas
so calc could be quite good for you all
right
um let's see a bunch of happy birthdays
here from people
um
here's a question from changgot changgot
changote enjoying your lectures from
south korea
is this thumbnail inspired by iron
maiden album covers
yeah it's uh that's the yeti see
eddie before
um somebody uh posted that and i thought
it was cool so i put it into the
the thumbnail itself uh tippo
kano's
so i think learning to read and
comprehend ancient greek is still
important for the modern philosophy
student
it depends you know it depends on what
you want to study
if you want to study plato and aristotle
in the stoics and epicurus and
you know middle platonus like plutarch
and you know
people all the way up to um
well in the east you know going going
all the way into byzantine philosophy
then you know you probably need it i
mean if
if you really want to study german
idealism instead then
learn german you know and you can learn
multiple languages as well
all right um
let's see tyler says
the videos have been super enriching
glad that they've been good
a lot a lot of other happy birthdays
thanks to all of you who are wishing
me a happy birthday here uh lekomir says
my work is a big source of knowledge and
wisdom but motivated ah good
motivated me to start some popularizing
of good sources
in the polish internet i'm happy to hear
that
because um you know we
youtube is is really english centric
anglo-centric yeah i guess that's how we
would say it right
um and
you know there there is a danger uh
uh you know the french have always been
harping on this but there's a danger of
of
there not being enough sources in other
languages
for the stuff that we're we're trying to
do right
and i'm always happy to see um
things happening initiatives happening
in other languages
so all right um
just skipped a little bit um
alex says thanks for explaining and
making hegel tangible for a layman
you're very welcome glad that it's been
helpful a.d what philosophers are same
as nietzsche like destroyers of
values i don't know if mitchell was
aiming at being a destroyer of values he
thought that
that was already happening nihilism is a
big problem in his view for
the coming century which was the 20th
century it would be a problem
if he were around today he wanted to
create new values
right and so i you know i think you
could say there's a lot of philosophers
who are inspired by nietzsche in that
respect or are doing
similar things but maybe not in the same
way as nietzsche you know like look at
mock
shaler the great german phenomenologist
um
who certainly took some stuff from
nietzsche but he's like well
he was wrong about this this has to be
recontextualized
or think about um other philosophers
that have similar critiques
of of you know modernity like
say gabriel marcel or martin heidegger
you know um
and are looking for not necessarily
creation of completely new values but at
least reconnection to
values in the past so i would say that's
that's
maybe a an avenue to look in um
scotch says happy birthday my videos
help
uh keep things in context well that
that's nice to see too
context is very important uh pavel
says happy birthday thanks for all the
great work provided through the years
you're very welcome
uh mad spanier uh i discovered you
getting
getting into reading albert camus really
enjoyed studying more about the stoics
and existentials through your videos
thank you so much you have an excellent
day oh you too i hope you have a
great time richard clemens how is
foucault different to nietzsche i mean
that's sort of like saying
how was um cicero different from plato
there's lots of places where they
they're not doing exactly the same thing
but cicero certainly
takes some stuff from from plato and
foucault
certainly took some stuff from nature
mark says i've always heard aging is a
privilege
with that said congrats on the big five
zero oh thank you
so this is a good place for me now that
i've actually more or less caught up and
if
i skipped over anybody i apologize you
know it kind of skips around on the side
this is a good opportunity for me to um
talk a little bit about some of my
reflections about turning 50.
so to start with like i said i never
thought i'd be this old
you know uh certainly not when i was in
my my teens
and then my my army days in college and
uh you know grad school and
you know working as a security guard or
in kitchens or wood cutters or janitors
or
you know then being a professor uh first
at the football
state university teaching in the prisons
and then
down in fayetteville state university
where i did teach one semester at a
north carolina prison and then you know
being up in new york
and uh being with with andy and then the
move back here to milwaukee
um i mean as i got closer to 50 it
became much more tangible that i would
sooner or later be 50
right but it's it's one thing to think
about it's another thing for it to
actually happen
and i think one of the things that i
i've been reflecting on this quite a bit
you know
as you get older some of those some of
you who
who are older uh can corroborate this or
say whether you think i'm wrong about
this or maybe it's just you know
some people do it some people don't and
then those of you who are younger this
is something you can look forward to
when you're younger you really do kind
of feel like you you have your whole
life ahead of you
and you can you can you know putter
around and piss away time and stuff like
that
on things that aren't as important and
sometimes you can even like be
bored and be like man how am i going to
kill some time here
you know i can't wait for time to run
out but as you're getting older
especially if there's a lot of things
that you want to do if you're engaged
with the world you're engaged with other
people
you look at things and you're like oh
man i'm going to have to do some
some prioritization here because i'm not
going to get to all of this
prime example of this is i've been able
to get rid of books
more easily now as i'm getting closer to
50
because i saved all these books and i
was like well i got to hold on to this
because i might do a research project on
this later and then
you know with some of them you're like
nah that's not going to happen in my
lifetime i mean if
i if i need to get it i'll go to the
library i don't need an actual physical
copy of this book anymore
um i'm probably not going to make that
enough of a priority
for um you know the life that i have
left to live
and and it's similar with other projects
you know
if i want to get the writing things done
i need to start making
time in the week in each day
to work on the writing stuff that i i
pledged i'm i'm you know
going to be doing i've got collaborative
projects with some authors and
i've got books i want to write there's a
lot of videos i want to produce
you know filling in gaps in the um
let's call it online curriculum that's
available there
i do want to develop a lot of online
classes i don't know that i want to keep
necessarily teaching as many classes for
local colleges and universities
as i'm doing because i'm not sure that
all of that is such a good use of my
time
i'll give you a prime example so i know
like teaching at milwaukee institute of
art design is a good use of my time
because it's minimal hassles they
respect the work that i do
the students are engaged and i'm helping
to form
young professionals going out there and
get you know philosophy into their
their heads um my work with milwaukee
area technical college
um there's a lot of hassles there's a
lot of bureaucracy
there's a lot of jumping through hoops
that are frankly a waste of time
um i keep doing it mainly because it
allows me to keep teaching in
the wisconsin prisons online and i think
that's an important thing to do
i don't know that i want to do that 10
years from now you know
marquette university um it's
it's fun to teach in the classroom their
online stuff is kind of a hassle to work
with the ctl people
i don't know that i'll always be working
with them you know and i've got my own
study with sadler online academy and i
think i'd like to be doing more
consulting work and more client based
work as well
so so it's all a question about how do i
how do i restructure things to make sure
that that happens
and i get enough time with my my wife
and my kids
and our one remaining pet and i get
enough time
to you know exercise and do the other
things that i enjoy doing taking
walks around here in milwaukee and
cooking and and uh you know also
meeting up with friends and doing all
those sorts of things so
it you know it's a good time when you
are at one of these
round number years like 50 or 40 to like
take stock and be like all right what am
i actually spending my time on
what should i be doing another thing i i
want to make more time for
is
getting this thing out of the case and
actually playing my banjo
from time to time and maybe learning how
to do it a
bit better you know i'm practicing that
i'm not always at a pure amateur stage
or um taking my
it was my my base and now it's my
daughter's base
taking that thing out and playing that
every once in a while so i think you
know
these are all things that you you kind
of put into perspective
uh as as you age i think for me too
having you know my dad go on when i was
uh
11 and he was uh only 36.
you know it showed me you anything could
happen right
my mom um she only made it to 54.
actually no she was 53 when when she
died
um she hadn't had her 54th birthday
she lived a lot so did he um
you know my my biological dad is still
alive and doing quite well he retired
recently and
he's uh in his 70s and uh you know
hopefully he lives into his 90s um
but you never know what's going to
happen right so i think it's really
important to put these things into
perspective
all right let me let me i see that
there's a lot of other new comments and
questions um
let me scroll up so
all right uh one two happy 50th your
videos help me make it through my
philosophy
masters i have no idea how you keep all
that information inside your head thanks
so there's actually a story there
part of it is because of the you know i
went to
what's considered a lower tier graduate
school
but we our prelims were tougher than
what people at elite schools did
because of the way our school worked at
that time not not anymore
at the master's level you had to take uh
what was called the comprehensive
examination so
you would study for it for about you
know the summer maybe
or a whole semester and you had a
reading list
and you would be answering four
questions
that you'd be given three possible
questions for each of these four
areas ancient philosophy medieval
philosophy
early modern philosophy 19th century
philosophy
and you were given a reading list so
like ancient philosophy
you know would include a whole bunch of
plato's dialogues
and you know a whole bunch of
aristotle's works um
some stoic stuff some epicurean stuff
some platinus
i think it was about it for that
medieval you know you had uh
augustine boethius anselm
um aquinas some occam
some scotus right and then modern was
was loaded up pretty heavy and so was
19th century
and and you would have three and a half
hours when you went in there you didn't
know what the questions were ahead of
time
and you had to pick one from column a
one from column b one from column c one
from column d
and write about it so you really had to
know your stuff right
or you could try to game it you could be
like well i bet there will be a question
on descartes so i'll study descartes but
i won't study hume
and then if you got there and there was
no take heart question you're kind of
screwed right
so i did the the route of like
i read everything on the list and
studied it and crammed it up in my head
in my in my 20s and then at the phd
level
i did that four more times because we
had a special thinker
uh exam i did hegel which meant that i
basically
i was i asked well what should i do and
i said and memorize the structure the
whole dialectical structure the
phenomenology and you know
the stuff that you think is important in
the science of logic too i was like
okay and that's what i did you know uh
and then we had like metaphysics and and
uh
philosophy of religion and epistemology
philosophy of science and value fields
which was ethics aesthetics politics
and because of the department we had
people who were analytic philosophers we
had continental philosophers we had
historians
and we had classical american
philosophers and they all put as much
stuff as possible into that reading list
so again i just studied everything in
the reading lists
you know and some of it i actually
studied in the original languages i
like i answered questions about
aristotle on the uh philos
on the epistemology thing from prior
analytics
and the it was funny i got a high pass
on that but
one of the uh instructors took me aside
afterwards and he's like
you got the greek wrong on that that's
how rigorous this stuff was
so when you go through something like
that it's sort of like going through
you know uh army ranger training in the
military
except for your brain and so you retain
a lot of that
and so that's that's been incredibly
helpful for me
as i went out to teach you know because
when you teach
uh unless you're like moving into a
research position you gotta teach a
while
i did you know all right max strong says
you look
35 greg uh well uh thanks
for that maybe if you're only looking at
the hair on top and not the mustache and
beard
which in the earlier part of uh
you know my 40s was all brown the way my
hair is but then i remember as it
started turning
gray and a lot of my friends are like
that too
you know um
changote says do i sometimes give
job-related advice to my philosophy
students
what would be your advice to a fresh
graduate with the least marketable
degree seeking career in marketing or
sales
well philosophy isn't the least
marketable degree
and neither is art by the way you know
i mentioned i teach students at
milwaukee school of uh
milwaukee institute of art and design
you know if you can like get a degree in
the liberal arts and you
do the sort of networking that you need
to do you you can walk in and say
listen i can do problem solving in ways
that your business grads can't do
i can do effective written communication
i can take you know arguments and
analyze them break them down
make them better there's a whole thing a
lot of things i can do but i actually do
give
well i mean when it's not covid times i
give workshops
on what to do with a philosophy degree
both at the undergrad and graduate
levels
so yeah
i mean if you're looking for a bit of
advice
i would say one of the things that's
most important is figure out what skills
you actually have and you've been taking
for granted
if you can write a dissertation you have
incredible research skills unless you
were you know your dissertation sucked
right
and you were lazy but for the most part
you've learned
how to acquire information how to
evaluate sources
being able to articulate that to
employers and say these are the things i
can do that your other people
may not be able to do as well or at all
i would be
of benefit to to your team that's that's
something that i think people have to
work on the other thing i'll say too is
i've learned through a lot of working
with
non-academics and non-philosophers that
the one thing that we're
really good at training people to do in
philosophy
is make distinctions and
if if we do it well it's making
distinctions at the right time
for the right reason and when you do it
people are like
holy crap this is magic right so i think
that's
that's really uh important
all right um lodentes says
just want you to know i really enjoy
your world of speculative fiction
discussion series
your very first few group discussion
videos were how i discovered your
channel
it's good yeah and i'm continuing it
right now i'm finishing up my reread of
st
leibowitz and the wild horse woman so i
can do my
second uh video in the new series
uh since you know we're back in covet
times right so
all right uh zeitgeist trying to read
through lock's essay concerning human
understanding i'm starting to think it
was a mistake it's quite boring
anyway happy birthday well locke is
boring
you want but you want more boring read
bentham you know
endless like exhaustive lists of
examples
but it's worth doing um it's still it's
still worth
reading i remember something that andrew
black
my uh he was a historian of philosophy
analytic philosopher trained but he was
also a really good historian
works in st louis now because he didn't
get tenure at southern illinois
um one of the things he said in our lock
class because we had a whole seminar
unlocked was
so a lot of you are complaining about
reading lock and what this
what what it's like and he said just
imagine to yourself
that this was actually considered to be
engaging writing
in the uh 17th century
times have changed when it comes to
style
so all right um
barklord every day is a smaller fraction
of your whole life than the previous day
yeah that's that's quite true
but you can also look at it going
forward and say every day
is a larger portion
of what's left of your life right
especially when you get to the last day
which is
that's it now you're at one uh not even
a fraction
uh victor says happy birthday i hope you
have many more
hope that for everybody else as well
um mark asks um
do i have any intention of writing a
speculative fiction book
i would like to um i would like to it's
a matter of finding the time i would
love to have the time to delve into
some of my favorite authors and say
what are the grand themes here you know
what did they do in their works
um it probably would have to be a series
of
books and i've always wanted to like
write a book too as a side thing
that would go through all of philip k
dick's books
and and say here are the ideas he's
taking from philosophy
from religious studies from psychology
from these other fields here's what what
the idea is here's what he's doing with
the idea sort of like almost like a
not something more than a glossary
but something along those lines
all right um
i just jumped a little bit let me
find this one here we go uh
victor says thanks for caring for
prisoners and teaching them philosophy
that's awesome
well i did more of that early in my
career than i do now
unfortunately the teaching that we do
here in wisconsin is all
online so and it's when we say online
it's not like normal online classes
they don't actually have contact with
the outside internet
they only have a moodle class site where
i've loaded up videos and stuff like
that so they can't do like discussion
forums or
the stuff we would normally do in a
class so they can't get the full
educational experience but
it's still it's still good you know i'm
glad we can at least do something
because prison education has been
disappearing
in so many states for so long
all right colin kaeper says happy
birthday love your work
thanks glad that you that you like it
bingers says in um
not sure who's whose uh accent it would
be happy birthday
greg could be english could be french
could be australian
right um
smoke says happy birthday professor have
a good one i'm gonna
definitely try to jake says uh on your
last stream i unfortunately got in late
couldn't talk in time
i asked what actions should a person
take or questions they should reflect on
when they aren't sure what to do with
themselves okay so this is probably from
ama
right um
now that's kind of it's kind of broad
but i think we can say
a few things about it so
maybe part of what you would want to do
is lay out what your
options are and if you can do that in
your head that's okay but maybe you want
to do that in
dialogue with another person or maybe
you want to write it down
you know and maybe it's something worth
doing not just on one occasion but on
multiple occasions
and then that can help you once you've
actually got things laid out
you can then look at each of them and
analyze them
in depth that might help as well
all right uh kennard says happy earth
day dr sandler is it earth day today
august 16th oh happy birth earth day
birthday i get it okay
it's like cockney rhyming slang i love
your epictetus lectures i'm glad glad
that you like him epictetus is really
you know a favorite of mine when people
ask like things like if you could only
have one stoic text left
i epito i can just stop you right there
that's the one i'm going to keep you
know that's my my favorite one
um lokesh says i started reading
aleister mcintyre's short history of
ethics
his interpretation of socratic
philosophy is so insightful mcintyre is
a good source
um there are some things where i don't
agree with him on
something um but usually
i'm pretty happy with what he's got to
say i i like i like his work quite a lot
all right um
that is it for the black bavarian i do
it in fact have another
beer on the side also from schwecker
something we we bought trying something
new
it's one of their interesting uh
it's called shock paro it's a gluten
free
african style ale made from sorghum
and millet that's pretty good it's kind
of cidery
you'll see it's quite light in color it
makes
a nice foamy there you can see
nice foamy head right
gotta let it subside a little bit and uh
mean what else can you say it's got a
can of floral
that's decent still you know prefer the
black bavarian but
um i thought i'd at least you know
introduce you to
one of our local brews
because of the sorghum and millet it has
a kind of interesting
aroma to it um like i mentioned it's
it's kind of fruity kind of floral
um also kind of earthy at the same time
the foam is nice too somebody i should
probably do
beer review videos right
that could be interesting all right
let's back back to this
so um retrogamer
says happy birthday hope you like the
gifts i opened a bag of corn chips to
liven up my mood
well you get your hair done like iron
maiden's eddie for the next just
wondering
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do
anything with my
my hair in particular that would take
like hairspray and stuff like that
and um you know i haven't done anything
special with my hair uh since the 80s
you know back then we'd like in a blow
dryer
we'd feather it some of you may remember
doing that sort of thing right um and
then like you know i'll
tell you a funny story so my sister of
course
was uh you know just a little bit
younger than me like at two
two and a half years and it was the
1980s and you know
we were all into heavy metal so of
course that meant that
her hair was long but she'd also like
spray it up with hairspray
and it would go up to about like in
about like here right
that was that was the thing back then
then it'd be all puffed out on the sides
and um when we moved
her when we she had like a a a mirror
and a dresser and when we moved that
that stuff
there was like resin from the hairspray
and it was like
a quarter of an inch thick because so
much of it sprayed
everywhere right but it's really kind of
gross when you think about it so
all right oh it's a retrograder two
thanks thanks thanks for the
the gifts he's talking about um books
um i have a amazon wishlist
that people have been buying things from
which are primarily
philosophy books uh speculative fiction
books
and then banned t-shirts um so
for those actually let me make it more
more general for those who've been
getting gifts from my 50th birthday
thanks so much for that
i really appreciate it i you know i put
a lot of thought into it saying well
what do i
really want you know what what is it
that i actually
want to have for my birthday and i'm
gonna go
hopefully if it's not closed down and
get a cigar from
uh one of the local tobacco shops um and
and have it in the park on my birthday
if if you know we can
if the whole area isn't closed off um
had some
beer that i like um i might
i'm also gonna i asked my wife to make a
german chocolate cake
one of my favorite cakes and she's also
gonna make spaghetti and meatballs which
has been one of my favorite dishes since
i was a kid
uh and so really all you know the only
things i really wanted were
books and and band t-shirts i couldn't
think of anything else
you know i mean i've got a good car uh
i've got most other clothes that i need
um
you know i've got a good computer i've
got a good uh
bag to carry it around in you know i got
my two instruments
that's that's really about it so yeah
kind of fortunate that way all right
uh charlie asks how do i live um well
you know like i think most other people
uh i work that brings in money and
uh you know we're pretty frugal we we do
order in occasionally but mostly we make
our own
our own meals from scratch here and
we're fortunate that both me and my wife
are good cooks
and uh you know we live in this this
apartment here i
go outside to take walks around the city
and um you know i teach online i
i uh work with clients and companies
that's that's really about it you know
um
all right nocturnal toothbrush quite a
name there hey friend you helped me
write my papers last semester don't
worry i cited you
i'm not worried about it um i'm glad
that the the videos helped in some way
uh damon any thoughts on philosophy and
humor hegel's socrates are funny but
tough to catch
yeah you know who else is funny but
tough to catch thomas aquinas there's
actually
there's a website out there stuff and
they're really subtle really dry let me
put in a plug too
for a a friend of mine michael connell
who's an
australian comedian who does stoic
comedy
really funny guy again if you like dry
humor
if you want other kinds of stuff he's
maybe he's not so funny but i think he's
hilarious
i i like him so much that when he asked
me to do a philosopher's commentary on
his comedy routine
i jumped at the chance to do it and that
that's out there as well
all right uh nicholas i finished my ug
dissertation on the commodification of
data today
very cool feels good and tempted to do a
masters
yeah i mean why not um
it certainly couldn't hurt and and the
commodification of data today that's an
interesting topic all right
um let me
just jumped again let me scroll here
um
cody says happy birthday know that
you're changing lives the sparking joy
of philosophy that that
that's really great i'm glad that the
videos
can do that um diogenes says
i know he said ballard wasn't on the
cards anytime soon but you mentioned
your red crash what do you make of the
novel wish you the best
it was okay i i didn't really get into
it that much
um maybe if i read more ballard i'll see
what
other people really like about the guy
um vishnu says happy birthday sadly i've
been watching your critical thinking
class videos it's great
please add more classes well
um i don't know that i'm going to add
more classes anytime soon because those
are
like recorded in the classroom and
obviously we're not doing face-to-face
teaching anymore right
but uh you know we'll see
mad spanish says wicked shirt i'm typing
for my thrash punk band account
writing about wrestling with the idea of
the absurd we have a current unreleased
song called
uni [ __ ] me well and truly yeah but
that's just dancing around being a drop
up or not working out my own issues
but i love studying and your channel is
nostalgic for me in an academic sense
well
that that's that's good um
yeah i mean i i uh i remember having my
year
in between grad school and undergrad
here in milwaukee when milwaukee was not
quite such a nice city
working just five blocks from here at
the hundred east building
as a third shift security guard you know
and then popping over to work in a
coffee house
and then crashing and working out and
coming back and doing it again
and listening to a lot of kind of angry
music
making a bit of music of my own and all
of that
doing that in my 20s all right uh
john says love your stuff happy birthday
have i read patrick j
dinan's book why liberalism failed no i
haven't read that
um let's see here
richard says happy birthday peace and
prosperity to you
you too as well um
ah here's a continuing thing from mad
spanish
what i'm basically saying is your
channel has been a really big deal for
me
having a reference for clearly
explaining often difficult texts
that said i would love to see more
trolley memes
well i'm not making trolley memes other
people got to make them and then i
aggregate them so i i wonder did i
did i i think i may have had like some
others in a folder
about what philosophers had to say yeah
because i did the first thing
and then i did covid19 so i think i do
have
a stock for probably memes and i would
like to do some other meme things as
well
where i'm showing like variations and
commenting on them
but it's a matter of finding the time uh
mark said beer reviews would be great
that would i i would enjoy doing that
because i enjoy drinking beer
vishnu has to throw some rain on the
parade i'm worried drinking beer makes
anyone fat not good for health
don't know if i can say this or not in
moderation i think it's fine
um you know yes if you're like drinking
a 12 pack a day
but you got to remember that i'm from
the beer producing region
of you know this is wisconsin and this
is milwaukee this is the beer city
so it's almost like a patriotic duty
right
uh same thing with milk and cheese here
all right um let's see
again it just jumped a little bit ah
here we go
sam scarborough birthday doctor said he
has helped obviously
with my ug studies of anselm kept me
engaged with philosophy as i move from
my humanities undergrad into studying
medicine good and you know
you can continue studying philosophy no
matter what
sort of profession you move into
you can always keep up with philosophy
it looks like we had an unstable
connection there for for a minute
uh fluctuation in the interwebs as i was
saying you can always
continue in whatever career you're going
into you can continue studying
philosophy
we're really fortunate in that so long
as we have the internet
all these techs are available for free
online you just got to dig around
you can find good web pages discussing
them
podcasts video resources we're really
quite quite blessed
victor says i'm drinking white claw
raspberry that's that's something i
haven't tried
um people are getting into those to me
those are those remind me of like people
drinking zima back in the 90s
all right retro gamer says strong ethics
is instinct is both short sword and
shield
against those who air and wrong foot you
or
is the distraction by a multitude of
pleasures the
first answer to tribulation any maxims
um i don't know that i have any maxims
off hand you know maxims are little
quips
but i mean
i don't i don't really rely too much on
quotes or
passages or things like that i just kind
of think about well
what you know what is the right thing to
do and it's like bringing to bear
people uh from from uh
you know classic texts
for me so all right uh
unters untersh communication
says happy birthday from germany any
thoughts on richard rorty and metal
related thoughts on black metal
uh the only ostensibly black metal band
that i'm i'm into is venom and that's
because they're part of the new you know
i listened to them when i
was a kid in the 80s and you know
they're part of the new wave of british
heavy metal
i don't really get into most of the
genre metals
you know i mean thrash is an older genre
that was around
in forming in the 80s and i do like
quite a bit of thrash stuff
um i i like you know uh
new wave of traditional heavy metal i
like power metal
and doom metal but that's that's
basically about it as far as the newer
genres
um richard rorty interesting guy he was
a big deal when i was in graduate school
um maybe undeservedly so i think
people probably won't be reading him
much you know 100 years from now
um so all right uh
carol says uh happy birthday i'm from
the philippines you've reached us here
you've been a great philosophy guide
some of us here trying to free ourselves
from external so that sounds
stoic uh i'm glad that you've you've
found
useful stuff uh in the videos or
in maybe stoicism today or
things like that um nicodemus says happy
birthday i just want to say thank you
for sparking my interest in philosophy
that's always nice to read as well
i'm glad to hear it corey says
i've been reading rousseau's discourse
on inequality do i think his views
regarding humans in a state of nature is
more accurate than hobbes no because i
think both of them are equally
inaccurate
so so uh
i don't think i don't think we have to
choose between them they're both
kind of imaginary stuff nick rasmussen
says uh happy birthday
your content is incredibly helpful for
my own self-directed study
yeah self-directed studies is really
where a lot of people are gonna be going
you know in the future
as our universities and colleges provide
less and less and charges more and more
i think that's you know an important way
to go
um ken says a very happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
as well uh petross are you a theist
yes um
let's see devonnie says just want to say
a book breaking down the ideas of philip
k
dick's work would be killer i'd read it
in a heartbeat and could even envision
teaching a class with it that would be
quite fun to do um i i have to see if
somebody else has already done it though
or not you know
um vincent says happy birthday you sound
like a minimalist based on your wish
list
not really a minimalist i just i've got
most of the stuff that i
i want to have you know i i've got um
like i said i've got pretty much most of
the clothes that i want to have like we
went on a
we go on like buying things and
i'm covered for for pants now for a long
time right or like
underwear socks go on sale or we jump on
that you know
um we also stock up on on food stuffs
when they're they're on sale so
all right gabriel says happy birthday
rock on lots of love
thanks man um
internet god happy birthday whoever the
hell you are
okay uh jonathan says here to wish you
happy birthday your videos are
tremendous help to me and help me
popularize philosophy among my friends
that's cool
um i'm not the mouth for these years
yeah yeah you know um i'm glad that that
you know you've got something you can
share that hopefully can reach them you
know that
again that's that happy medium i'm
trying to shoot for
lucas says loved your nietzsche phase
video going through my nietzsche phase
now
that that is often indeed a phase that
we go through
um drunk philosopher recently finished
kant's first critique thought the
antinomies is one of the best things to
ever read
thanks for helping me get into reading
philosophy critically glad glad it could
help
kai or kay says what are your thoughts
on numbers existing outside human
perception i've heard both sides of the
argument but can't come to agree holy on
either side
i haven't thought about that for a long
time i would have to devote more thought
to it
uh vishnu says what made you get an
interest in philosophy at what age did i
get an interest i think i've always been
interested in
what we call broadly speaking philosophy
ideas and
examining them and seeing the
connections between them
i didn't i didn't really understand what
philosophy
was until later on
and very often the way philosophy gets
taught
it's it's so truncated we don't we don't
teach that much stuff
you know that would really appeal to
people uh i was fortunate in that
i wound up like having a few
good interactions and a few good
teachers here and there and i just kind
of continued
all right rachel dean says happy
birthday you're the reason i got an a
in continental philosophy glad to read
it gabriel says happy birthday from
chile love your lectures
thanks so we're at the end of the
questions and comments so i'm not gonna
do any more right now um we've spent
about an hour here i've
had a few reflections let's do one final
toast
uh since i still have a bit of beer left
um
and what should we toast to this time
around
let's say to all of us remaining
safe and healthy and
covered free and able to
proceed with our studies and our lives
well
and our relationships over the coming
year
victor says to health that sounds good
so a little virtual clinking glass there
for all of you
and i hope all of you have a great day
thanks thanks so much for uh joining me
for this
um my actual birthday as you remember is
is two days from now but the dn the
democratic national convention
is happening just a block from here so
we may not
uh actually have internet who knows
what's gonna happen but i'm glad all of
you could join me
and uh hope you know this this winds up
being a good decade
after we get through this terrible 2020
for for all of us